I thought we could all enjoy a little
bit of classical music but revisited in
a more electronic form I actually enjoy
writing music also but the reason I
presented that was to just talk about
the fact that typically when we talk
about visualizations or computers in
general we tend to dismiss anything that
is more than a few years old we want the
latest greatest but then we can find
really some gems in the history of
visualization and speaking of history
what is interesting is that for the
stem-and-leaf plot we just need one
thing the digit the numbers 0 to 9
however we can improve on that in
certain ways by adding some graphical
elements and so from and just mentioning
the numbers from medieval times all the
way to the 14th century the changes were
quite abrupt and many of them however
from the 14th century up to our day on
the digits in our type of scripts the
glyphs are the same so it got to a point
where people were comfortable with it
and what it means is that really it's
effective so as far as graphs and bar
charts we can find some as early as the
1300s nika the hem in a Latin manuscript
which was printed this is a printed copy
from the 1480s introduced some of these
charts and really it is to talk about it
says latitude in boost which really it's
the horizontal movement or the velocity
and acceleration even before Isaac
Newton knew it was considering these
things interesting right but there are
also elements that are tabular or
graphical
in or semi graphical but are not
stem-and-leaf plots so if we look at for
example bus transfers or timetables in
general look like they are arranged a
little bit like a stem-and-leaf plot and
even though a Wikipedia might tell you
that there are some stem-and-leaf plots
that are timetables in reality the time
but this time and leaf plot is supposed
to be a distribution plot and the
timetable is not the purpose of it is
not that so it's a little bit different
however they do look similar in fact in
one publication from 1919 we see this
chart and if i zoom in a little bit
we'll see these are numbers and I could
have also add maybe perhaps area charts
and we would have seen perhaps a legend
on the side giving us more detail but we
had to go back and forth back and forth
here we see the numbers directly but
again it's not quite a stem-and-leaf
plot and if we continue over there you
go 1946 and Dudley add a book for
engineers where he's basically producing
a transcription table so that's crème
transcription table as columns however
since they are not stacked it's not yet
quite the stem-and-leaf plot and of
course as far as graphical
representation sometimes it's very valid
in fact Jacques birthday in 1967
introduced a book that in English is
named semiology of graphics if you don't
have a copy of that I would definitely
recommend it it's a great book and he
introduced some concept of sorting based
on visual cues instead of sorting by
value like by age or x amount of tefft
in this case which was the information
that he wanted and then he could see
some kind of linear relationship across
so sometimes it's worth it but we can
also go overboard when we are doing
graphics roberto bochy in 1968
introduced this concept of graphical
rational pattern
so this is a little harder to read than
numbers everybody agree all right so I
mean it was an interesting concept but
perhaps taking a little too far so in
1970 in the classroom John pookie
introduces the stem-and-leaf plot what's
interesting to note is that to this day
it is used in the classroom and as early
as the fourth grade in norcal and i
believe it's starting in the fifth grade
that they introduced them to dis plot if
we continue in 1972 he published a paper
that gave a little more traction to his
concept in are basically a book in Ford
George snedecor some graphic and some a
graphic display and of course in 1975
hoaglin a colleague of is a wrote on
some fortran code to be able to generate
de stem-and-leaf plot but really this is
the book in 1977 that he ended up
publishing with the stem-and-leaf plot
and it also covers the box plot so again
this is kind of one of those a very
important book in the history of
statistical graphs as far as that is
concerned but there was a danger lurking
and what is the danger comes in the form
of something we called a floppy or a
floppy disk yes and why is that a danger
anybody wants to venture a guess well in
1977 the Apple two came out initially it
was with cassette so storing data on
cassette was kind of awkward and nobody
would want to store a lot of information
because you weren't sure you were
getting it back however with the floppy
now you could generate with your
computer pseudo-random numbers and
create large amount of data well big
data for the time right I mean although
it's probably about a hundred K here
still that meant that the
democratization of computers such as
Commodore 64 even less expensive or in
businesses like the IBM PC with its CG a
color display ah that was basically
trouble for distending leaf plot because
it was text on the console green screen
right and at the most three hundred data
point what do we do beyond that but at
the same time there were some people
that were holding on into the beauty of
the design our understanding robust and
exploratory data analysis mentioned
several points as to why it is so
effective and I want going to all the
details because we were in that time and
Edward Tufte also in the visual display
of quantitative information makes a
mention how the glyph of the digit is so
effective and of course he's a big fan
of data to ink ratio if you're putting
ink on paper it better represent data
fact I experienced that firsthand
talking to him and that was kind of a
all right I got this incredible new plot
I'm going to show it to him and he's
going to be like oh yes this is
marvelous and that's actually not what
happened so he said well your font is
horrible what kind of thought are you
using and well the colors wow they're
way too intense you know them that a
little bit and so I was on the message
that he gave me so I went back home and
was I okay well I guess he's right
because we are so caught up sometimes in
the technology or whatever we've been
working on that we're focusing on one
aspect but in reality we have to look at
everything so we worked on that and
continued on so if we looked at perhaps
a demo right that it's better than just
always talking about these things first
distribution plot I'm sure you know most
of them I won't go into the detail of
the data that I'm capturing here but
basically Medicare payments for 2012 and
you know your typical pandas manipulate
we'll look at one HP HCPCS code which is
94 640 which represents nebulizer
treatment let's see if I can bum the
font a little bit and if we run a
histogram well we have kind of a 90 of
the distribution and it appears that
there were charges from maybe 0 we don't
know for sure all the way to perhaps 400
but we can't really tell right if we
look at other distribution plot perhaps
you're familiar with the rug plot
basically these little lines each line
is an observation and of course when
there are very dense such as on this
side it's hard to actually see the
individual detail strip plot same
concept but there are also distribution
plots that are pretty effective such as
this one from Seaborn that goes into a
bit more detail plus it allows us to do
secondary graphs such as a perhaps a KDE
in this case or a KDE inner rug plot
combining oh yes perhaps I should
mention the last one the box plot right
another actually as I mentioned John
kekis invention there so this data gives
me a lot more detail but some people
don't like it personally I like it but
what do you do to get from that point to
actually see the data well so the
stem-and-leaf plot allows you and this
is the output of stem graphic here
allows us to see the individual data
point so on the extreme left is the
aggregate it's a count so basically it's
telling me how many records I got in the
first row up to second row up to third
rows on all the way to the top and
saying that I have 900 data point in
that little chart
here and I can actually read the
individual values I can also tell you
that $40 is the median right here and
that fifty dollar seems to be a pretty
popular payment that is requested and
all of that from the little distribution
plot so let's dig a little bit deeper
into that so stem graphic is a python
module install from victory installs I'm
graphic and if once you install it
current version is zero point three
point three you can also get your help
on it on the package itself or on the
individual functions there's also a
command-line tool lets associated with
it and the command line tool allows me
to for example i'm listing i got win
excel file here i will run stem on the
excel file and stem automatically looked
at what's the first numerical field that
is not looking like an index
unfortunately that one wasn't very
exciting but i know for a fact that
there are some dollars in the seven
columns I'll pass that and see what I
can see there and now it goes from
20,000 all the way to 200,000 of course
I'm on the command line so it's text but
there are other methods of our functions
available one is stem hist one is a stem
KDE stemline and stem graphic itself so
when I started looking into data
actually I was reading over last year
over the holiday John two keys book and
I was like why is it not used and I
started looking and on the rosetta code
there were like hundreds of different
implementations in every language you
can think of and so that was the data
set here that they were using it's a
list a plain Python list here and so I
decided to see if I could replicate that
and it looked pretty nice overall and of
course I decided that I
should be able to change the colours of
the different elements and make it go
more flexible from that perspective it
also works on synthetic data or any data
really in this case I'm just generating
numpy arrays and the data here will be
rendered in this case I decided to
replace the bar by underline in orange
different color it's pretty simple I
just add a few keywords to do that
there's quite a bit of flexibility or I
could do a histogram a black histogram
like this of course now I've lost my
significant glyph which is the digit so
I can no longer see the exact values but
because it also is uh using my plot live
in this case it can use safe fig and
save to a PDF SVG PNG or whatever other
format that i would like what about if I
like our and I want to do my data
munging in our well I can do that too
and in this case I just wanted for the
brevity I put it in the same notebook
but it could be in a separate note book
but in this case I'm actually using our
magic from our py 2 and that way I can
pull which I did two things here right I
let me bump the size a little bit I
actually got the data set empty cars
MotorTrend cars classic and I got just a
car weight from that set and then also I
got the whole quake set which if you've
attended the tutorials yesterday there
was one tutorial that covered that set
in particulars I figured well let's
include that one too and so if I applaud
that I actually seen the multi-modal
approach here and again we have quite a
bit of the data here we have actually
900 points here again if I look at a car
wait there was only 32 and that's
because the set only includes that many
but I can clear
see the min and Max here which are about
1,500 pound and 450 for 24 pounds for
the heavier vehicle so again I can do
some basic and not so basic quick look
at my data this way i can even a i did
mention i would introduce a new
programming language again heard of
today or maybe you've heard of it it's
coconut which is functional programming
in python compatible with python
actually so i can actually use python
statements and do a pipeline in this
case I'm just pushing from this side all
the way to stem graphics so I'm actually
sampling a hundred from this list that's
generated by this here so it's kind of a
convoluted example but just to say that
yeah there's a level of compatibility if
you can bring it into your notebook
environment here alrighty briefly on the
design and implementation I just wanted
to mention it looks fairly simple but
when you start looking at how to count
the number of bins and you'll see in the
performance they know why that is
important the number of bins is how many
data points you'll accumulate in each or
how you going to slice and dice your
data and if you don't get it right you
can get from some Wharton for me
informative visual display or front or
to basically okay this is useless to me
so that's pretty important to look at
that so I took in a hybrid approach
based on the number of points that are
to be counted so for a smaller data set
I take one approach and if you want more
detail it's in the little booklet if you
didn't get a copy of the booklet there's
a few more copies so after the talk feel
free to stop and grab one okay number of
data points this is where you're
wondering this guy is talking about 300
they
point nine hundred data point I have a
million data point or 750 or 150 million
or a billion data points what can this
tool do for me well so this is where
sampling and other techniques come into
play and I won't go into the detail yet
i will continue on to the next demo and
it'll make it a little more sense one
thing also so of course there's you have
to consider when you create a new
visualization how am I going to inform
the the reader or the person looking at
this this chart how it works so a legend
that's important to have so we spend
some time thinking about that well I'm
saying we I mean to as me basic like so
secondary plots also again because we
saw in Seaborn how that can how
convenient that can be in fact you could
maybe in Seaborn maybe have a normal
curve or a double gamma and all that and
compare and it's like oh yeah this exact
same distribution right persistence so
since we are sampling one of the
interesting feature is it maybe you
don't want to do today or wrangling it
handles quite a bit already it figures
the first column it'll take that little
sample would be nice to be able to save
that sample and not just have it for the
visual display that I can continue my
analysis from that sample particle e if
I'm talking about a set that's a billion
records I don't want to have to query
death too often and the default well I
mentioned you know ah as tufte mentioned
Oh font ugly color too bright so you
have to think about these things
performance demo when I say performance
there are many aspects of performance
one is the speed at which things run but
also so I just loaded 700,000 records
look at the histogram so pandas has a
very fast histogram it also has a plot
that will by default do it
it's almost like a histogram that's not
sorted so I couldn't in theory may be
sorted and have something useful but
it's also a little slower according to
time it once it's done it'll tell me it
takes about five second / 4.2 4.3 7 so
that's actually a little bit better than
usual and I actually I'm running
everything off of the little USB hard
disk external just so you know so now
i'm importing seaborne and we'll look at
the dist plot that we demoed earlier Oh
what's happening should I panic no I
know actually what's going on basically
Seaborn is telling me that there are
values that are undefined right here and
so what I have to do is drop in a before
I actually call the plot itself so if I
didn't know that well I would lose some
time or so and so forth so let's see how
it did hmm it looks like just one bar
there's a little bit of detail here and
I can see the max value but there's not
a lot of information on this screen and
so that's too bad let's see how stem
graphic does first of all it took two
hundred millisecond about the same or
all faster than this plot but let's see
what it did fine for us so the minimum
value is zero the maximum and I Shrunk
the screen so you guys can see here on
the screen but it's 5.26 so on and so
forth million dollars and I can see the
individual data point I can see my
median and so I get really some
infirmity display with basically default
behavior except for me adding the random
state so i can reproduce the same graph
for every time i do this presentation
and it ran at multiple time so let's
make excel cry 12.5 million rows
New York City yellow taxi trips data for
2015 will look at just because this is a
live demo and we want that much time
will just run on one month so 12 million
rows instead of 150 million and so just
I have a little class here to time this
by the way if I were to look at the data
true word count anybody familiar with
word count and while word count does it
sting a WC is basically just doing that
exactly as giving me the number of lines
words and bytes in that file and it took
seven point six second which is pretty
good for 12 million records right it's a
pretty big file and so if we run stem
graphic on the same data of course I
have to load it in a panda's so it'll
take a while obviously right but what it
will do is it will go through that data
figure out what the minimum the maximum
value how many records are there and
we'll build the graph oh it actually
came back in 17 second tube and so I
knew that so all right so so we did get
a an output fairly quickly now let's
look at the larger data set and that's
the 150 million records I as I mentioned
I've already run this because it takes a
little longer even just looking at a
word count on this and timing it it ran
it a few times and the best time was
four minutes and 50 seconds so that's a
sea program optimized for doing one job
and it took almost five minute and us if
we loop through the 12 files and just
read them and that's all we do we just
load them into memory and then put in
the next took eight minute and a half
and the last one stem graphic from disk
again
running this now here's what's happening
because it is way more than the RAM on
the laptop it requires 60 gig of ram
minimum actually I was able to load it
on one node that that's 60 40 again it
was able to load all the data for in New
York City 2015 so its bigger than the
ram so pandas will not work so I'm using
what's that didi Tang that I'm using if
we go back at the top import desk data
frame as DD and sewed ask allows me to
have a data frame that's on disk in this
case however even better than this is
that I could also instead of doing read
CSV I could do it from HDFS so if you
have a dupe cluster or basically any
cluster that has HDFS capability or you
could use s3 or so and so forth then you
can actually pull the data and you can
whereas this took six minute you could
actually given enough node make this
interactive and that is pretty
significant of course there are other
visualization tools that are able to
handle very large data Sarah mentioned
data shader I yesterday but again this
is a tool that's very simple to use of
the only difference is instead of using
my pandas dataframe i'm using the dashed
data frame for very large set and stem
graphic knows about that now remember i
said sampling i'll go back to that so in
term of the sampling of what's happening
there is that task actually does things
a little different than pandas in fact
if i could make one change i might
suggest a one change to the code i had
to use a fraction and not the actual
number of samples i wanted and what that
means is i am required to get the count
of data do the division to get the
fraction that I want and pass that to
dash and then execute that because desk
is building just intent and then you
have to do compute to actually do the
thing that you want to do so its
built-in into stem graphic so it knows
about
mention lists numpy it knows about data
frames and dashed data frames from that
perspective and again um as I mentioned
performance is not just about the time
it takes it's about how good the tool is
I mean if I have to spend another hour
drilling and figuring out what it's
spitting out to me then that's not
really useful but these are graphs are
used on a regular basis and really um
it's very effective one of the thing
that I've built also is that when it's
samples and it gets back and it
calculates the ratio and it's tried to
figure out how many rows or in columns
and how it will look if it thinks it's
like no that's not going to be visually
appealing or unusable that means there's
a good chance that the sampling are hit
one of those edge cases right i mean
there's always if you sample enough
times you'll get a sample that's not
really representative of your data it
happens from time to time so what i did
is i just added something very simple
which is a secondary sampling um I would
love to see people try to as their own
functions and try to experiment with
that and see what else can be done from
that perspective so that's part of the
future work and since I've put
everything on github then you can also
go and help out and try to figure out
there's quite a large to do actually so
maybe a speaking of large need to bump
it up a little bit um again so that
means that you can actually look at the
code try to figure out how it works if
you want or just use it as it is they've
install and you have access to it it's
only tested on Python tree and you might
think why would that guy is kind of like
not the friendly right just to know that
the many of the projects are actually
all aligning
themselves to basically start offering
within some months or even a year in
certain cases python3 only and since i
had the limited amount of time to
develop this I figured well i've been
using python tree for exclusively for
over a year now i think it's okay so
alrighty so that pretty much concludes
the presentation any questions from the
audience all right just wait for them
microphone so sometimes there's more
than one line like there's like a blank
line that doesn't have a number next to
it yes some of the right and I wasn't
quite sure how to interpret that one
that happens yes and so in the booklet
that explains a little bit more but what
it is is that a John two key when when
in design his stem and leaf plot EDA
find from the get-go three different
approach on to this one is the simplest
which is just I have did the digit and
the first on the stem I do so stem dot
leaf times the scale I'd say the scale
is a hundred so I have 2.1 times a
hundred 21 in the case of plots that are
maybe too squished and you want to gain
a little bit more vertical so this is
the number of bins that a histogram
would calculate in this case what we do
is split from 0 to 4 on the first or if
there's no data it actually just skips
it if it's the first line at the bottom
or if it's the last one at the end and
it's 5 and above so 0 2 4 5 and above I
mean 529 on the second line there's
actually one more even more split a
graph to a plot and that goes from 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 already this when you go
and split it what I found out is that
people will have a hard time associating
which line
which which and so I don't use it much
beyond EDA work so when I'm exploring
data I'm looking at the data i'll use
maybe the split but if I'm publishing
for somebody if it's appropriate if they
actually want to see the number and part
of the future work that I pointed at is
research in perception which is one
thing also research on persuasive power
of text and graphical elements because
it's been shown that if you have a lot
of visual aspects but not a lot of
numbers people are wondering a little
bit more about your data if it's true or
what but if particle financial areas and
whereas if you have a table with a bunch
of numbers or would this looks very
serious so apparently there's there
might be a an impact by having you know
visual and colors and at the same time
the actual numbers on the chart that's
an unproven theory at this point but it
would be interesting to look at
thank you great talk the Stanley plot
was really designed for type of graphic
representation data it's a static thing
in today's age with interactive graphics
have you thought of perhaps having just
a histogram but if you mouse over it
becomes a stem-and-leaf and people can
see the data so it becomes more
interactive that way yes actually so
I've been plucking with Sarah quite a
bit on bouquet and I've actually been
using bouquet for quite a while also but
I didn't feel comfortable enough
weighted when I started dad which was
back in January of this year to try to
do that right away uh I add some you
know more algorithmic problems to solve
the distributed computing issues things
like that but yeah definitely it's also
in on the big to-do list on the github
repo definitely interactivity would be
quite marvelous for sure thank you for
this and when I look at this I see like
a visual representation of like
descriptive like a descriptive
statistics right you've got your min max
you've got your distribution maybe it's
time to be you know you can sort of
visually see what you might get in like
a descrip you know like pandas
description um but descriptive that that
can always hide that can hide part of
the nuance of a data like what um what
do you like to combine this with to
really get a sense of your data of what
do you think it's good for what do you
think it's not good for yes okay so
first of all and like transactions and
dollars and things like that tend to
have a distribution that it lends itself
well to these things I've been looking a
ton at Medicare data things like that
and you see patterns it's like it raises
questions things that you didn't expect
to find necessarily it's like why is
there such a peak in this area why this
number shows up so many times this is
like not normal there's something weird
there and for sure it I would want to
investigate more so there are some areas
like that at work
out pretty good um when you have very
few data points I mean less than 30 I
don't think it's worth the effort to or
the time to issues that and there are
data that basically just a table is the
best approach I mean you just have some
numbers that you want to show and that's
the goal then you know might as well do
that but when you do want to again
salaries house prices on so yesterday
there was a tutorial Don and I did on
house prices and you could clearly see
the distribution of the house prices in
Seattle based on the data and it was
fairly informative so right away you can
see these patterns emerging now even
better would be maybe to combine you
know clustering and colors based on
these clusters and things like that
automatically then it would provide even
more information obviously and because
it's a graphical representation then
that should be possible all right I
think if we don't have any more
questions and our time is up let's go
give a big hand for France quality on